les altos violoncelles contrebasse
tout ce groupe là fait la même chose ok
mais c'est là-bas les violons tous les
violons
journée de répétition ce mercredi à la
Commanderie d'Élancourt 90 enfants âgés
de 5 à 11 ans sont venus s'entraîner
avec leur nouveau instruments donnés en
janvier dernier dans le cadre du projet
demos l'objectif ce jour-là est
d'observer les progrès de ses apprentis
musiciens en deux mois de travail deux
mois trois mois maintenant de travail
avec les instruments et bien oui on
passe du bruit à un certain manière de
manier l'instrument de le de le de faire
un son un petit peu plus stable que
juste faire n'importe quoi quand on
débute en fait
les progrès en fait on les voit assez
vite à avancer des progrès rapides qui
ont permis à ces enfants venus de 50 ans
ni villes et de Chanteloup-les-Vignes de
tomber sous le charme de cet univers
musical je pense ça très bien et j'aime
bien l'instrument que je fais je sais je
vais le rameau
je suis un petit peu la combien
et je crois que c'est tout les nouveaux
musiciens se produiront avec leurs
nouveaux instruments lors d'un concert
exceptionnel le 28 juin à la Meurice de
Trappes encadrée par des professionnels
rattachés la Philharmonie de Paris ses
apprentis apprennent depuis des semaines
à jouer trois pièces pour ce spectacle
dont une création collective c'est un
peu comme faire de la cuisine avec les
ingrédients qu'on a donc voilà
aujourd'hui j'avais tel ingrédient tel
ingrédient qu'est-ce qu'on va faire et
puis voilà on a le but c'est de faire un
plat avec avec ce qui nous tombe sous la
main et ça c'est très exaltant parce que
du coup on est sûr c'est comme si on
travaillait sur mesure avec eux d'ici la
fin de l'année ces jeunes feront trois
répétitions de groupes afin de peaufiner
tous les détails pour présenter au
public un spectacle à la hauteur de leur
investissement